c'est non non nous allons maintenant
pour l'entier écouter la colère du
peuple français
que feront les par l'organe majestueux
le procureur général de la république
est proche française ouais
a beau jeu des proches quel que soit
votre plaidoirie je tiens à vous dire
publiquement bravo merci monsieur on va
quand même vous couper la tête des gros
si tu trouves s'il vous plaît laissez
s'exprimer le procureur hans weijs jr
français belges belge chers amis
socialistes et communistes appelé la
raison pour essayer tu as raison mon
président mon chien monsieur le ténor du
fado monsieur le déserteur opportuniste
paranoïaque vulgaire monsieur le
professeur mon cher guy vous permettez
que les appels montferrier
mesdames et messieurs les jurés public
chéri mon amour
adieu me tripote qu'elle et moi ma [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
les mois ma bitaoui l'émotion m'étreint
l'anc ouest mégarama voir ce sérail ma
caisse c'est gai c'est votre attention
au départ
oui françaises français chers amis de
château chinon
c'est un homme brisé par l'émotion il
s'adresse à vous aujourd'hui
c'est pourquoi mes chers amis de la
gauche mon cher monsieur colucci pour
chergui je vous demanderais
exceptionnellement de ne voir sous la
robe austère de la justice que le coeur
d'un homme comme les autres
un choeur tendue vers vous et qui
tambourinent fébrilement sur ses deux
ventricules comme n'importe quoi qui
tambourinent ray fébrilement entre de
machin pourquoi pas confusion est elle
si grande aujourd'hui chers amis chers
camarades travailleurs sympathique cher
roger hanin qui m'écoutent et peut-être
mes respects monsieur anoh au fait
quelqu'un a t'il de nouvelles de
monsieur à 9 oui moi ouah qu'est-ce
qu'il va mieux mais très bien à bien la
très bien et je suis sûr qu'ils
emmerdent d'ailleurs n'empêche que je
décerne quelques muette d'interrogation
dans l'oeil torve des jurés pourri
d'office quand je parle monsieur ne me
dites pas que vous ignorez ce qui est
arrivé hier à rosen c'est pas vrai faut
que je vous raconte
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir monsieur
colti que roger hanin exerce l'honorable
profession de resther derrière east
présidentielle il ya dans ledit métiers
qui se perdent ah oui mais celui-là il
pas perdu il reste derrière le président
or le nouveau président dort toujours
sur le dos il ya des gens qui se tourne
coup à droite un coup à gauche le
nouveau président non élu fasse pas au
lit en tout cas comment tu le sais or
hier soir quand le président s'est
couché il avait oublié de débrancher son
anneau d'une image monsieur alain est
attachée à la personne du président
certes mais pas par aucun fil tangibles
en tout cas pas par de la jalousie si on
remporte on a le droit de parler par
parabole quand même même dans une radio
nationale at et que je sens hélas de
plus en plus insidieusement manipulés
par les laïcs
sauf quand on relit radio vatican pour
les accidents de paepe évidemment
alors bon quand le nouveau président de
la république s'est couché il a
complètement oublié de dire à son reste
heures derrière east personnel d'aller
se faire frire des merguez plus loin si
bien à ce stade
à ce stade de mon récit je signale aux
parents dont les enfants seraient
directeur de programmes de télévision
il est temps d'aller coucher car ce
n'est pas une émission pour connu les
petits fait pas pipi au lit déjà couché
dans votre froc depuis des jours ça
serait dommage
j'envoie les petits au lit car en effet
la suite de mon récit est horrible quand
le nouveau président s'est couché il n'a
pas vu que roger hanin était finalement
resté derrière lui et il s'est couché
dessus avant de s'endormir en rêvant à
sa prochaine intronisation vous dire le
calvaire que fut cette nuit pour roger
hanin je ne puis admis asphyxié écrasée
par le poids de l'histoire
n'osant pas crier pour ne pas réveiller
les vieux démons de la droite très
nombreux dans ce quartier très élégant
de paris l'ancien gorille croyait
devenir chèvre
ce qui est encore une image on a le
droit
ben oui c'était une chèvre et
sympathique serait pas d'hier
les expressions ou maxime française
comportant des chefs sont nombreuses
sont légion oui pauvre monsieur alain il
ad'autant plus souffert qu'ils avaient
gardé sur lui à même la peau sous son
tee shirt dit baccarat et dire aux
pompons qu'il devait aller agité demain
à la fête organisée à marseille sur le
thème des hommes nouveaux pour une
france net avec gaston defferre dans le
rôle de chaque médecin
quel émoi m'habite disais tout à l'heure
je suis en effet très ennuyée mesdames
et messieurs les jurés car je pensais
que c'était mère teresa que nous jugions
aujourd'hui et oui elle n'a pas pu venir
s'excuser
j'ai dû la remplacer au pied levé et oui
mais je me réjouissais davance d'envoyer
cette femme au port où les charges qui
pèsent contre elle sont écrasantes comme
disait roger hanin hier soir mère teresa
incite notamment une certaine catégorie
de personnel décharné à la
surconsommation en période de crise et
elle contribue aux déséquilibres
écologiques en s'acharnant à détruire
des millions de staphylocoques blanc
comme par hasard mais au lieu de mère
teresa qui voyagent au ban de la famille
qui est ce sombre pitre naguère
hongroise et rosé boudinée dans sa
salopette le voici ramassé sur son bide
comme une majorité sortante
le voici tassé sur lui-même comme un
giscard à la mi mai j'aime jusqu'à ce
n'est pas mère teresa c'est le père
l'hérésie pas plus pas plus que le
nouveau chef de l'état sur son beau je
n'ai l'intention de m'étendre sur
monsieur colucci
mais s'il qualifie comme disait naguère
encore monsieur lecanu et de cette belle
voix de piano mécanique aéro fage qui
lui sort du cul de poule
lecanu il avait dit que j'étais en
dessous de la ceinture alors que giscard
venait juste de dire qu'il était au
dessus des partis
[Rires]
on est quand même à le faire remarquer
c'est une histoire il sait d'historique
saouler je tenais le faire remarquer
parce qu'ils l'ont gardée n'ont pas fait
gaffe
que savons-nous vraiment mesdames et
messieurs les jurys chers camarades
jurés
pardon de ce monsieur colucci qu'ils
n'arrêtent pas de dire qu'il s'en va
alors qu'il fait rien qu'à s'incruster
qu'il est d'origine transalpine certes
et alors oui et alors direz-vous dans
transalpine il ya transall qui veut dire
billancourt et aldrin qui veut dire
renault donc ce que l'uci est d'origine
ouvrière d'ailleurs je lis dans le
dossier d'instruction qu'il a raté son
service et qu'il ne sait même pas tenir
un club de golf
tout ça se tient par ailleurs je me
demande si l'accusé ne serait pas un peu
[ __ ] sur les bords on me dit en effet
qu'en apprenant la défaite électorale de
l'ancien président de la république
vous étiez comme un italien quand il
sait qu'il aura voilà et c'est bien là
le nageur de rigoler devant un étalage
de nouilles thierry seni coeurs croisés
de pl est avec vous devriez avoir honte
on sait que l'uci car enfin que faites
vous de la solidarité humaine en anciens
candidats qu'ils ont dans le qg ce qui
arrive et où vous devriez vous serrer
les coudes
du môle fallait pas le dire vous n'avez
leroy coude bien sûr ils me l'ont pas
dit je veux dire père de coups de même
ah oui j'en ai deux mois d'autant que
giscard au moins il a eu le courage
d'aller jusqu'au bout de son combat
alors que vous-même colucci avait
honteusement trahi l'espoir qu'avait
mise en vous plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'abrutis j'ajouterai je sois
mon tout dernier mot sur cette élection
présidentielle de 80 car il est temps
maintenant de tirer un trait sur
l'avenir et de regarder ensemble vers le
passé qui nous attend j'ajouterai
j'ajouterai que le président sortant n'a
pas tout perdu puisque plus du quart des
voix se sont portées sur son nom dès le
premier tour
le quart et le cap ce n'est pas rien
mais ses collants et c'est d'ailleurs
pour cela qu'on ne l'appelle plus en
france que valérie j'ai le cas dans le
train mesdames et messieurs les jurés
coluche ne mérite pas votre josiane quoi
votre clémence
ah bon je pense que ce serait
excusez moi je pense que ce sera une
assez bonne idée de lui arracher
quelques uns de ses membres inférieurs
encore oui avant de lui tremper les
boues restantes dont la harissa
bouillante et de le ligoter sur un pot
de chambre plaindra communiste blanc
avec des yeux rouges d'après guy bedos
qui est le plus grand comique de france
[Applaudissements]
quand paul grimault et malade
d'après guy bono ce supplice et un peu
trop doux pour coluche il suggère qu'on
oblige coluche
là je n'ose pas le dire à écouter en
entier le discours de réception de
michel droit à l'académie française
mais là on peut pas parce qu'on aurait
il ya des règlements
et d'ailleurs il paraît que la
l'académie
maintenant que cette socialiste ils vont
plus être vieux c'est non non
[Musique]